c'est dur d'avoir un nouveau départ quand le
passé est dans ton esprit je pense qu'on a
des choses à régler
[Musique]
mais c'est un nouveau moi
on va Bettelheim ton crédit est revenu
étincelant je t'ai cherché toi  '
ne suis pas sur les réseaux sociaux que tu pourrais être
une sorte de monstre, on me dit que LA est ce que
tu en fais
qui tu t'entoures
[Musique]
bonjour tu aimes c'est agréable de te rencontrer
amour peut-être que je devrais courir mais je ne  je ne veux
pas quelles sont tes intentions avec ma
soeur
parfaite morsure parfaite
[Musique]
que veux-tu Candace tu l'as
encore fait n'est-
ce pas c'est à propos de ton accès
elle t'a vraiment blessé
[Musique]
s'il t'aime c'est la chose la plus
dangereuse
[Musique]
Je ne laisserai pas cette situation se détériorer,
rien ne va sans que tu aimes
être ce que tu veux tu es tellement
spécial J'aimerais être spécial
[Musique]
toi